a ukrainian court sentences another two
russian soldiers for war crimes this
time to 11 and a half years each in
prison for shelling a village in eastern
ukraine investigation processes and then
court processes will be very long period
of time ukraine's prosecutor general
says her office has now identified 600
russian war crime suspects on the front
lines in the east russian troops have
now taken part of civero donetsk the
bombarded city an important target for
the kremlin as it aims to control the
entire donbass region
president vladimir zelinsky called the
situation there very difficult as he
accepted a pledge of artillery from
slovakia as president but slovakia along
with the czech republic and hungary is
exempt from a newly agreed european
union ban on russian oil imports by the
end of the year the country will
effectively benefit uh from from this
exemption
without the necessity of playing the
role of the bad boy or or the
blackmailer what uh what orban
hungarian leader victor orban led
objections to an all-encompassing eu ban
calling it unbearable for his country's
economy
germany's economic minister called
orban's desire for an exemption
short-sighted and self-interested this
is a topic where we will come back to
and
where we will still have to work on but
it is a big step forward according to
one estimate the eu has paid russia more
than 77 billion canadian dollars for
fossil fuels since the war began
effectively funding the russian war
chest more than half of that money spent
on oil most of the rest natural gas the
gas is of course much more
difficult than than oil already was
all the next sanctions will be more
difficult and that's especially true
because germany and its population of 85
million relies so heavily on that
natural gas redmond shannon global news
london